The Walking Dead has said goodbye to
Rick Grimes et has the scoop from Andrew
Lincoln and the zombie killing cast
about the episodes most shocking twists
and turns let's rewind after brutally
freeing himself from a metal rod Rick
Grimes spent the episode in a state of
blood loss delirium as he tried to
outrun a massive herd of Walker's I
think it was about date 2 of filming I
and I asked Greg Nicotero who was
shooting the episode how many pints of
blood of the human actually hold because
I'm not sure I'm going to make it
through the credits as Rick struggled to
stay awake he reunited with a few
friends we lost along the way during a
series of heartstring tugging dreams I'm
so sorry for what happened to you by the
end of the episode a near-death Rick
sacrificed himself to blow up the bridge
full of walkers and save the lives of
his loved ones
[Music]
but in a shocking twist our hero
survived rip was taken away in a
helicopter to safety and according to
the cast it seems like we've not seen
the last of Rick Grimes I mean you
haven't seen him
you know this show has a has a way of
throwing you a curve ball at the last
minute I'm just gonna say that I think
the way he leaves oh this is gonna be
interesting for the fans and I think
that it's gonna do it's gonna propel the
story in a way that it never would have
been able to go before and I think that
the fans are gonna dig it but it sucks
not having a luckily the Grimes family
legacy continues thanks to this
unexpected flash-forward
yes
Durkheim's
you